لا يمنع المطر عادة
الناس من منطقة الضوء الأحمر في كابوكيتشو في طوكيو.
أتذكر زيارتي الأولى هنا
منذ خمس سنوات في عام 2015 ، كانت الشوارع الرطبة الباردة
في هذه المدينة التي لا تنام
دائمًا ممتلئة
تمامًا مثل المتاجر التي تصطف على جانبي هذه
القاعات ذات الإضاءة الخافتة التي تعارض الدعارة
القانون في اليابان ، لكن الجميع يعرف ما هو
حقًا للبيع سريعًا بعد خمس سنوات
حتى عام 2020 ، فإن فيروس كورونا يفعل ما
لا يستطيع المطر إطفاء أضواء النيون
في كل سنوات عيشي في طوكيو ،
لم أر كابوكيتشو هذا فارغًا عادةً
هذه الشوارع مبطنة  مع النساء
اللواتي يحاولن جذب العملاء إلى
متاجرهم ، فإن المحلات التجارية مغلقة الآن
والنساء اللائي يتعين عليهن إيجاد طرق أخرى
أكثر خطورة لكسب العيش ،
طلبت منا امرأة تتصل بميكا إخفاء
وجهها وتغيير اسم عائلتها
لا تعلم أنها كانت تعمل في مجال الجنس لمدة
عشر سنوات هذه الأيام مع إغلاق جميع المتاجر ،
فهي تذهب مباشرة إلى العملاء في
كثير من الأحيان من الرجال الأكبر سنًا ، وهو عرض محفوف بالمخاطر مع
انتشار الفيروس بسرعة  kly بالطبع أنا
قلقة على صحتي ، كما تقول ، لكنني أشعر
بالقلق أكثر بشأن كيفية النجاة وماذا لو
لم أستطع تحمل تكلفة شراء الطعام لأن فتاة صغيرة
أرادت ميكو أن تصبح صحفية
لم تنجح الحياة بهذه الطريقة لم
تطلبها  إنها تطلب
مساعدة
عاملات الجنس لا يمكنهن التوقف عن العمل ، كما تقول ،
لكننا لا نريد أن ننشر الفيروس
الذي يقدر بـ 300 ألف عاملة في الجنس في اليابان
مؤهلون للحصول على
المساعدات النقدية الحكومية لفيروس كورونا ،
ويقول المدافعون عن العاملات في مجال الجنس أن المال ربح '  يكاد يكون
كافيًا لإبعاد معظم الناس عن الشوارع ،
هناك الكثير من التمييز ضد
عاملات الجنس ، كما يقول جونيشيرو كاكوما
قبل ظهور طفله الصغير لفترة وجيزة ،
هناك العديد
من الأنواع المختلفة من الأشخاص في صناعة الجنس ،
كما يقول ، مثل الأمهات العازبات اللائي يحتجن إلى كسب
المال  قد يكونون خائفين من
فيروس كورونا لكنهم أكثر خوفًا من
فقدان وظائفهم ، تحاول مؤسسته غير الربحية
مساعدة العاملين في مجال الجنس في
وظائف جديدة ، ولا يخشون إخبار
أسرهم بالوظائف التي فازوا بها "  ر
وضعهم هم وأطفالهم في خطر
ريبلي سي إن إن طوكيو
[موسيقى]